Hi everyone! I'm Brian Krueger with CollegeGrad.com,...
...and this is the Job Search Minute.
Here's another tough interview question.
"Why should I hire you?"
The easy answer is that you're the best person for that job.
And don't be afraid to say so.
But then, back it up with what specifically differentiates you.
For example, "You should hire me because I'm the best person for this job."
"I realize that there are likely other candidates who also have the ability to do this job,..."
"...yet I bring an additional quality that makes me the best person for the job:..."
"...my passion for excellence."
"I'm passionately committed to producing truly world-class results."
"Let me give you some examples."
Are you the best person for the job?
Show it by your passionate examples.
This has been the Job Search Minute,...
...for more career information, please visit CollegeGrad.com